crazy. It's je It's not You're noticing it finally. Well, I I
mean I I did. So, the reason why is that I I sent a photo to
a friend of mine. You can probably guess who the friend is of
who who I sent the photo to. Uh it was this one, right?
Uh it was this one, right? I sent this photo to him the other
day. Are we supposed to know or does that matter? Who was the
friend? homie is off the team. Cuz I had seen it and I was like,
you know, we used to be a everybody used to be able to get along
and, you know, disagree and things were fine and everything was
okay. But then over time things got more and more radical. They
got more and more extreme and they got more and more serious
and it's been Yeah, that's you guys. Like, yes, Donald Trump
has got like 16 different [__] pros against him saying
the government is so out of control that [__] all
[__] I just said I miss the old days and you dropped
a wall of text talking about Trump. Why are you like this? Things
got more and more radical. They got more and more extreme and
they got more and more serious and it's been Yeah, that's you
guys. [__] it. [__] the dude, the firefighter
guy. Uh, [__] Trump. [__] the people
that support him. If one of you were in the crowd and you're
a conservative fan of mine and you end up, you know, getting
blown away or whatever the [__] I'm making fun of
you the next day on Twitter. I am 100%. Yeah. I um for Anna,
that's [__] For just like Queen, I'd kill him if
I could. I'd show the [__] house and do it. Um but
not for Anna. No is what you're saying. Yeah. No. What the [__]
Like why would I even want to do that? Like what am I want to
kill her? What? Like that's [__] [__]
I do want somebody to kill justical though or laugh or So there
you go. Apparently what am I going to dox her? The rioting needs
to [__] stop. And if that means like white redneck
[__] militia dudes out there mowing down [__]
protesters that think that they could torch buildings at 10 p.m.
then at this point they have my [__] blessing because
holy [__] Like yes, Donald Trump has got like 16
different [__] TTRO's against him saying the government
is so out of control that [__] all the courts have
had to step in and say stop. You can't deport people without
due process. You can't have [__] quit proquo. Hit
user deal.